- You need something to be excited about
when you wake up in the morning,
and something that you're doing
that has a purpose.
Balance is important.
I think that you have to remember
to find some time for yourself.
I have a strong will,
and I'm very determined.
I always look at the glass half full.
I try to have a positive attitude.
- Move those hips, Kris, come on!
(rhythmic clapping)
(cheering)
- Whoo!
- I feel like I don't have the --
- Now merengue!
- What's up, Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that you have the ability
to do something special
that can change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to
learn from Kris Jenner
and my take on her top
10 rules for success.
(whooshing)
(inspirational music)
- You need something to be excited about
when you wake up in the morning,
and something that you're doing
that has a purpose.
And if you do something that you love,
and you have this
amazing energy behind it,
it's like, it makes life so much better.
And you can develop something,
and create a career for yourself
out of something that you love to do.
A lot of how you live your life
and how you succeed in life
is who you associate yourself with,
and who your friends are.
And my parents taught
me that my whole life,
and I heard my friends' parents say it,
and then Robert Kardashian drilled it
into my older four kids,
most of their lives,
and it just was ringing true,
it's like you associate
and hang out with people
that are like minded,
or that you want to be like.
And then you go out and do it.
Balance is important.
I think that you have to remember
to find some time for yourself,
because if you're not
the best that you can be,
then you're not good to anyone else.
So I think balance is about finding
and catching yourself,
making, scheduling, like
I'll schedule a massage.
It sounds silly, but I carry all my stress
in my neck,
so I just, if I can get that relief,
once a week, or once every two weeks,
I feel really blessed.
So I think you have to find the thing,
whether it's exercise,
I exercise every morning,
it changes my whole day.
If I don't exercise, I'm thrown off.
So I think that you have
to listen to your body,
and do what makes you feel your best
so that you can do your best.
Otherwise, you're no good to anybody else.
I have a young daughter, Kendall,
who's 16 years old.
Her dream in life is to be a model.
That's all she's ever wanted to be.
And now she's going to be on the cover
of a major magazine in September.
The girls were just on
the cover of Teen Vogue.
Kendall and Kylie are getting
one of the most incredible
business educations
that I think is possible in the history
of all little at that age,
because they're constantly,
they go to their business meetings,
there's one business meeting they went to
with Ryan Seacrest, and his whole team,
Adam Sher and everybody.
And they were at this
long conference table,
and after the meeting,
Ryan was like, wow, that blew me away.
They were amazing,
because they show up,
they are ready for the meeting,
they've done their homework,
and they've got all these things
that they're working on right now
that's going to blow you away
when you hear about it in six months.
I'd raised four kids in
this opulent lifestyle
with this amazing,
anything they wanted,
there was never a fear of,
a money thing,
they had their very privileged lives,
and so then when I got
married the second time,
and it wasn't the same pocketbook,
it was much different,
and I was faced with,
I've got to learn how to get it together,
and so the fear was that I
would disappoint anybody,
because I am a people pleaser,
but I'm also very,
I have a strong will.
And I'm very determined,
so once I set my mind to something,
and I knew that this had to happen,
and then I found a way to make a change,
and that's what was so
rewarding and satisfying,
because I would work so hard all day long,
things started to happen,
because I figured out a way to
have an income for my family,
and then the hard work didn't scare me,
because every time I
would go to bed at night,
and put my head on the pillow,
I was like, this is so,
I had such a great day, this felt so good,
and I worked so hard.
- Kylie had a pop up store in New York,
which I heard --
- She did this last week, yes.
- And the turnout was --
- Crazy.
- Really crazy.
- There were thousands
of people that showed up.
And it was quite the scene there
in New York City,
but it turned out really well.
- I mean, look at that, people were there
days before it opened.
- There was one woman who
camped out there with her kids
for like three days before it opened,
and I felt so bad,
but Kylie's so proud of those shops.
And she has mostly an e-commerce business.
- Mmm-hmm.
- So to do this is just
something she likes to do,
she's going to, she thinks,
I think she thinks that
she's going to go on,
on a national tour now,
so she'll do the different cities,
and she's having a really good time.
- But she's selling things
with your face on it.
(Kris laughing)
Did you know that?
Like, there's a lighter right here,
by the way, it's like
$12 for that lighter.
(audience and Kris laughing)
Did you know that?
- I did not know she was doing
any merch with my face on it
until it came out and she kind of did it,
and surprised me, and I was like, oh boy!
(audience laughing)
- I mean, doesn't she have
to ask your permission?
- Well, I could sue here.
- Exactly, exactly.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
This is a major lawsuit.
(Kris laughing)
- That's why I'm having you here,
to educate you that you should take --
- Thank you, Ellen.
- But I think it's just
crazy that she's putting --
- She, you got to laugh at yourself.
I mean, when I saw this, I was,
I thought it was so funny.
That one's a little X-rated.
- That's blurred out because
she's saying hello --
- But she does,
her and I have a really good relationship
and all my kids have such
great senses of humor,
and we're so silly all the time,
and you have to have a good sense of humor
and not take yourself so seriously.
- Yes.
- How do you manage being a mother,
wife, and such a huge businesswoman?
How does it all happen?
- It's, I feel sometimes
like I have a different job every day,
which I enjoy, because
there's a lot of diversity,
and there's always something different,
and I think that when you're
passionate about something,
it comes easy,
but the key is being very organized,
making a lot of lists,
and I'm a control freak,
so sometime it's hard to give things up.
When I do something, I
don't really think of,
I always look at the glass half full.
I try to have a positive attitude.
I try to see through the mud,
and say, this could be
a really great thing,
because I'm going to do it different,
or I'm going to make this work.
I'm always very, I'm
very stubborn, for one.
And I don't like to let things go.
So if I start doing something
and it's not going well,
I think I'm so persistent
that I will do it
until I feel like it's good or right.
- So you have this next generation
- [Kris] Yes?
- And the two younger ones,
- Yep.
- You put --
- Kendall and Kylie.
- In the spotlight as well.
- Yes.
- Is that going to keep
your family relevant
for another 15 years?
- Well, here's the thing
about that question.
I don't, it's not about
keeping the family relevant.
It's about, and this is what
I've always taught my children.
Find your dream.
What's your passion?
- I bet you girls are getting
a workout, aren't you?
- Yes.
- And having a really good time.
- Totally.
- [Kris] Can we try it?
- Sure.
- [Kris] Can you show us something?
- Come over here, this.
- I just want to do the
sexy walk and the shake.
- We want to see if --
- Yeah, I want to do that.
I don't know if it's
going to look the same,
or have the same effect, but.
- Everybody stand on your feet,
you in the audience, let's get up,
everybody up.
- Get up, we want to see
if Kris can do Dancing with the Stars.
(rhythmic clapping)
- Stand with your feet
shoulder width apart.
And just start walking in place.
Then merengue, move your arms.
- Woohoo.
- Woo, this is the merengue.
Sexy.
- Merengue?
- Merengue.
Then start with the basic
salsa, are you ready?
Stepping to the front, salsa to the front,
salsa to the back,
that's good, excellent!
Woo, salsa to the front,
move those hips, Kris,
come on.
Woo!
- Woo!
- I feel like I don't have the --
- Now merengue!
- I feel like I don't
have the flair you do.
- Oh come on, yes you do.
- You're great, Kris.
- Now we're going to do
side to side cha-cha.
- What are we doing?
- Side to side cha-cha.
- All right, do it.
- Stepping out to the side, here we go.
Side, cha cha cha, move those hips.
Side.
- Woo!
Careful, cha, cha, cha.
- This is dangerous.
(rhythmic clapping)
- Cha, cha, cha, side.
Cha, cha, cha.
Now you're really engaging
your core muscles.
- Your abs look great, ladies.
- I've noticed, they do.
She's right, they do look good.
- Okay, merengue!
Now one more, can you learn one more?
- Okay, one more.
- It's the cumbia cha-cha.
- The what?
- Cumbia cha-cha.
- Cumbia.
- Stepping back on your left, here we go.
Back, cha, cha, cha.
Cumbia, use those arms.
- Got to get the arms in.
- Arms for more intensity.
- Ah, wrong arm.
- Right?
It's all about the expensive.
- Right, cha, cha, cha, cumbia!
(rhythmic clapping)
One more.
Cha, cha, cha.
Merengue!
- I love this!
(cheering and clapping)
Thank you guys so much for being here.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jaye Cherie asked me to.
If there's someone you'd like to vote on
for the next top 10,
check out the link in the description,
and go and have your say.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Jane Cassell.
Jane, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word,
and for posting it on your
social media accounts,
on your LinkedIn.
I really appreciate the support,
and I'm so glad that
you enjoyed the reading.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
- What motivates you to keep going?
Because you really don't
have to do anything
if you don't want to, you know?
- You know what?
I think that for me,
it keeps me alive, like inside.
Spiritually and just with my passion about
what I want to be able
to teach someone else,
and I think that it's important
when they asked me to do this,
I thought, wow, what a great opportunity.
I thought it was a such a perfect idea
for a private school to
be able to bring this to,
I thought I had something to share.
You know, I've had to kind
of figure it out myself,
from the ground up,
taking kind of nothing and
making a business out of it,
and figuring it out,
and if I have anything
to offer somebody else,
it would be so exciting for
me to be able to do that.
Instead of just my five kids,
I can only bitch at them
for so many hours a day
before they just tune me out,
but to be able to have it
as an organized education
and come in from time to time
and be able to give a seminar or lecture,
and be a part of such an amazing process,
especially an international school,
because I love traveling so much,
and I love learning
something new every day.
As long as you can keep on learning
and then to be able to share something
with someone else,
I think that's amazing.